Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je suis venu ici, car j’ai besoin
de vous tous pour une révolution.
Une révolution positive
et civilisationnelle.
Nous avons besoin d'une révolution.
Nous sommes confrontés à 3 crises majeures
concomitantes et intimement liées.
Une crise alimentaire et démographique,
une crise écologique, mêlant perte
de biodiversité et pollution,
une crise climatique.
Nous sommes la dernière génération
à pouvoir peut-être juguler les impacts
de ces trois crises.
La prochaine pourrait être la première
à en subir sévèrement les conséquences.
Alors, plus de sobriété va être nécessaire
mais ça ne va pas suffire.
Il va falloir inventer des nouvelles
solutions et pas seulement technologiques.
Inventer des solutions naturelles.
Et peut-être que le fondement
de la vie sur Terre,
les algues, la plus grande ressource
inexploitée au monde,
pourrait à la fois nourrir la planète,
ou y contribuer,
et rétablir les équilibres
de nos écosystèmes.
Au cours de ma carrière dans
l’agro-alimentaire et de mes voyages,
j’ai pu constater les limites et les
impacts des systèmes qui nous nourrissent.
J’ai pu surtout voir le visage
de la faim dans le monde.
Nous avons la chance
de pouvoir l’ignorer, ici, ce soir,
mais un milliard de personnes
sur notre planète souffrent de la faim.
Tous les jours, nous avons
300 000 personnes en plus à nourrir
sur cette planète, tous les jours !
Dans les 50 ans à venir, si nous voulons
nourrir l’intégralité de cette population,
il nous faudra produire
autant de nourriture
que dans les 10 000 ans passés.
Ce défi est impossible.
Impossible, car les rendements
des grandes céréales
décroissent depuis des décennies,
car l’expansion folle des villes
grignote nos terres cultivables.
Impossible, surtout
car nos systèmes alimentaires
sont devenus les principaux responsables
de l’accélération des crises
climatiques et environnementales.
Impossible, et pourtant…
Et pourtant, si on prend un peu de recul,
on regarde notre planète Terre.
En fait, c’est une planète Mer.
Une planète bleue.
Couverte d’océans, à 72%,
qui ne contribuent aujourd’hui qu’à 3%
de notre alimentation en calories.
En fait, nous sommes sortis
de la préhistoire, voici 12 000 ans,
avec la révolution verte,
lorsque nous avons arrêté
d’être des chasseurs-cueilleurs
pour devenir des agriculteurs.
La civilisation.
Mais nous n’avons jamais franchi
cette étape avec les océans.
Nous sommes encore des chasseurs-pollueurs
dans l’âge de pierre avec les océans.
Il faut rentrer
dans la civilisation des océans
et cultiver les algues.
Au passage,
si l’envie vous prenait de réparer
les écosystèmes maritimes
au lieu de continuer à les briser,
les algues seraient
vos meilleures alliées pour le faire.
Donc, si certains d'entre vous pensent
encore que les algues sont gluantes,
malodorantes et inutiles,
il est temps de changer de logiciel.
Les algues ont façonné notre passé
et détiennent les clefs de notre avenir.
Tordons le cou,
tout d’abord, aux idées reçues :
il n’existe pas de mauvaises algues.
Les sargasses en Caraïbes,
les algues vertes en Bretagne,
sont avant tout
les symptômes d’un problème.
Leur prolifération
est due à une agriculture
toxique et intensive
dans les régions environnantes.
Car tout ce que nous déversons
sur la terre finit dans la mer.
Ces algues vertes sont riches
en nutriments d'intérêt.
Mais valoriser ces algues reviendrait
à ralentir la nécessaire transition
vers une agriculture terrestre
plus vertueuse.
Ainsi, les laisser pourrir et en faire
des nuisances est un choix politique.
Il existe 12 000 types d’algues, 12 000
types de macroalgues dans le monde.
Nous savons en cultiver…
une vingtaine tout au plus,
seulement en Asie, où cette culture
a commencé voici un demi-siècle
pour répondre à des contraintes
démographiques extrêmes.
Aujourd’hui, l’Asie cultive 35 millions
de tonnes d’algues par an
pour 15 milliardsd’€
de chiffre d’affaires,
8 millions d’emplois et qui contribuent
à nourrir plus d’un milliard de personnes.
On pourra quand même se demander pourquoi
une seule région sur cette planète
a appris à cultiver une ressource
qui n’a pas besoin de terre,
qui n’a pas besoin de nourriture,
qui n’a pas besoin de pesticides.
Et ça paraîtra peut-être absurde
de le rappeler,
mais les algues n’ont pas non
plus besoin d’être arrosées.
12 000 types d'algues très différents.
Les macroalgues ont 1,2 milliard
d’années d’existence et d’évolution.
Pour vous expliquer tout ça,
il y a un demi-milliard d’années
seulement,
ces macroalgues vertes ont migré
vers les continents
créant la vie sur terre,
créant surtout tous les végétaux
qui descendent de ces macroalgues vertes.
Aussi aujourd’hui, une algue verte
est bien plus proche d’un fraisier
ou d’un chêne qu’elle ne l’est
d’une algue rouge ou d’une algue brune.
La différence entre une algue verte
et une algue rouge au niveau génétique
est supérieure à la différence
entre un éléphant et un champignon.
Ne riez pas,
cette diversité est importante
car elle offre
une égale diversité d’innovation
pour répondre aux trois crises
qui nous menacent.
Nourrir le monde tout d'abord.
Les algues
sont des bombes nutritionnelles.
Elles sont riches
en nutriments essentiels, en oméga 3,
en protéines, en iode, en fer,
en zinc et tant d’autres.
Contrairement aux plantes,
quand on sèche les algues,
elles conservent leur structure
et leurs nutriments.
On peut ainsi les transporter
sur des milliers de kilomètres
pendant de longs mois, sans aucun besoin
de chaîne du froid.
C’est une excellente nouvelle,
tant pour les populations qui ont faim
que pour notre climat.
Au Japon, les algues représentent
10% de l'alimentation.
Elles contribuent là-bas
à l’exceptionnelle longévité
des habitants de cet archipel
et à leur très faible taux de cancers,
d’obésité, de diabète
et de maladies cardio-vasculaires.
D’ailleurs Hippocrate nous le disait :
« Que ton alimentation soit
ta première médecine. »
Les algues sont anti-cancérigènes,
anti-inflammatoires, antivirales,
antibactériennes, analgésiques,
antifongiques
et sont les prébiotiques naturels les plus
puissants pour renforcer notre immunité.
Partout à travers le monde,
des innovations de rupture
dans la médecine
devraient voir le jour grâce
à des molécules extraites des algues.
En Chine contre Alzheimer,
en Norvège contre la mucoviscidose,
un peu partout contre le cancer.
Depuis des décennies, les médicaments
qui améliorent notre transit
sont fabriqués à base d’algues.
Nous sommes des descendants de microalgues
qui flottaient dans l'océan
voici quatre milliards d’années.
Elles sont la matrice initiale, la Source.
D’ailleurs, Sapiens, nous,
sommes ce que nous sommes
grâce à des algues.
Il a été prouvé que seul un apport massif
sur des milliers de générations
en acides gras polyinsaturés
qu’on ne trouve que dans les algues
et les poissons,
a pu permettre à notre cerveau
de devenir si gros.
Alors il faudra retrouver
ce lien perdu avec les océans,
retrouver le goût des algues.
Et là, j’entends certains d’entre vous
qui se disent :
« Mais ce n’est pas bon, les algues ! »
Alors, j’invite ceux-là à goûter
une pomme de terre crue
ou une fève de cacao.
Immangeable !
Alors que du chocolat
et des frites, c’est mieux.
Il va falloir apprendre
à cuisiner les algues.
J’en entends encore là qui me disent :
« Mais moi, ce que je veux, c’est juste
une côte de bœuf bien saignante. »
Ok, d'accord, mais alors au moins,
nourrissons nos animaux avec des algues.
Il paraît quand même plus pertinent
de nourrir un saumon d’élevage
avec des algues locales
et riches en protéines
qu’avec des tourteaux de soja OGM
qui ont dévasté l’Amazonie
et voyagé sur la moitié de la planète.
Mais ce raisonnement vaut aussi
pour les animaux terrestres.
Les algues vont améliorer leur digestion
et donc leur bien-être.
Les algues vont surtout améliorer
leur système immunitaire
permettant de réduire
les besoins en antibiotiques.
Chez les bovins, les algues offrent
une spectaculaire promesse
pour réduire les émissions de méthane.
Pour faire très court sur ce sujet,
versez quelques grammes d’une algue rouge
sur tous les repas des bovins
de cette planète,
et l’impact sur notre climat
sera équivalent
à arrêter toutes les voitures
du monde du jour au lendemain.
Depuis des générations, sur les littoraux,
les paysans amendent leurs terres
avec des algues.
Elles renforcent naturellement
la richesse des sols
et renforcent la résistance des plantes
au sel, au froid et à la sécheresse.
Elles peuvent ainsi remplacer
les pesticides et les engrais minéraux.
Remplacer ces produits chimiques
sera une nécessité,
faute de matières premières
pour les produire.
Mais sera une nécessité
surtout pour limiter les polluants.
La deuxième crise, la crise écologique,
les pollutions.
Et là, vous allez me parler
de pollution plastique.
C’est celle qui vient à l’esprit,
ça tombe bien.
Les algues fournissent
un excellent substitut au plastique.
J'ai ici un sachet de bonbons en algues.
Je peux l’ouvrir, manger
les bonbons à l’intérieur.
Quand il est fini,
je peux jeter le packaging dans la nature
puisqu’il est biodégradable
et compostable.
Et je peux même faire mieux,
je peux le manger.
Voilà.
Plus de 35 start-ups à travers le monde
travaillent sur des solutions à base
d’algues pour remplacer le plastique.
Mais quand on y pense, le plastique
est produit avec du pétrole,
lui-même issu d’algues mortes
et sédimentées
depuis des millions d’années.
Nous avons bâti la prétendue réussite
de notre société récente
sur des algues mortes.
Essayons-les vivantes maintenant.
Des fermes d’algues vivantes
vont surtout apporter
des services écosystémiques
incommensurables
à la biodiversité alentour.
Elles vont nourrir la vie aquatique
et vont lui fournir des habitats naturels
nécessaires à sa reproduction
et à sa survie.
Cette vie aquatique, rappelons-nous,
elle a produit la moitié de l’oxygène
sur Terre, un souffle sur deux.
Nous le lui devons.
Les forêts d’algues à travers le monde
couvrent une superficie équivalente
à toute la forêt amazonienne,
mais elles sont deux fois plus productives
en biomasse et en biodiversité.
Il faut s’en rappeler, car ces forêts
d’algues sont vulnérables
aux perturbations anthropiques.
En Californie, la plus grande forêt
d’algues du monde
a perdu 80% de sa superficie,
entraînant la disparition
de 800 espèces marines et terrestres
dans les dix dernières années.
Il y a un incendie sous les océans
et faute de caméras et d’images,
personne ne s’en occupe.
Il faut replanter, préserver
et surtout cultiver les algues,
sinon elles disparaîtront et nous avec.
Au passage, les algues vont offrir
une solution exceptionnelle
pour lutter
contre ce changement climatique.
D'abord car les algues vont contribuer
à la décarbonation de l'économie.
Elles vont remplacer le plastique,
les fertilisants,
peut-être les biocarburants et sûrement
les fibres synthétiques et naturelles.
Mais elles vont surtout absorber
beaucoup, beaucoup de carbone.
Certaines algues poussent
de 40 cm par jour
pour atteindre 40 mètres de hauteur.
Tout au long de leur vie,
elles perdent de la biomasse
qui finit au fond des océans.
Faute de bactéries
pour dégrader cette biomasse,
elle reste avec tout le carbone
qui la compose,
prisonnière pour des milliers,
des millions d’années.
Les algues représentent ainsi
une fantastique pompe à carbone
capable de renvoyer ce carbone au fond
des océans de là où nous l’avons sorti
depuis un demi-siècle.
L’événement géologique Azolla,
survenu il y a 50 millions d’années,
tient son nom
d’une petite plante aquatique
qui a proliféré sur les océans et coulé,
faisant baisser la température
terrestre de 20 degrés
et créant le climat que nous connaissons
encore aujourd’hui.
Au passage, ces forêts d’algues
vont créer des sources d’emplois
et des revenus,
notamment aux femmes,
dans les populations côtières
où les ressources de la pêche
vont inexorablement disparaître.
Car on ne mène pas une révolution
sans s’attaquer aux injustices sociales.
Alors au final,
qu’y a-t-il qu’on ne puisse
faire avec des algues ?
Presque rien.
Que sait-on faire aujourd’hui
avec des algues ?
Presque rien.
Alors que manque-t-il pour initier
ce nécessaire changement ?
Eh bien, vous.
Il nous manque vous.
Nous sommes tous
les acteurs de ce changement.
A chaque décision,
nous dessinons le monde de demain.
Nous sommes tous des activistes
environnementaux qui, trois fois par jour,
pendant les repas,
pouvons décider de voter
pour une ressource bonne pour
notre planète et pour notre santé.
Nous pourrions commencer par renommer
les algues, appelons-les légumes de la mer
pour comprendre
comme elles sont délicieuses.
Appelons-les forêts des océans pour
comprendre qu’il faut les protéger.
Il faudra surtout en parler
autour de vous.
Favoriser l’émergence d’une nouvelle
génération de scientifiques
qui aura appris des erreurs terrestres,
appris de l’impasse des OGM
et de la monoculture industrielle,
qui saura dessiner une nouvelle
aquaculture régénérative et intégrée.
Ils seront les pionniers
d’une permaculture des océans
capables de fournir
des ressources presque infinies
tout en rétablissant l’équilibre.
Ce combat n'a rien de personnel.
Je suis père de trois enfants.
C’est un engagement
intergénérationnel pour l’espoir.
Quel projet de société
peut-on bâtir sur des peurs ?
Nous nourrissons nos enfants
avec des peurs et des promesses de drames.
Nous devrions lutter pour leur fournir
des solutions et des sources d’optimisme.
Alors, grâce à ces forêts de la mer,
grâce à ces légumes des océans,
cette prochaine génération,
on pourrait s’en souvenir
comme de la première sur Terre
qui aura su nourrir l’intégralité
de sa population
tout en réduisant
le changement climatique,
en restaurant la biodiversité
et en diminuant les injustices sociales.
On pourrait s'en souvenir ainsi.
Mais ils auront besoin
de chacun d’entre vous.
Chacun d'entre nous.
Alors pour chacun d’entre vous,
cette révolution des algues,
elle doit commencer ici, et ce soir.
Merci pour eux.
(Applaudissements)